each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
alright so it's a my pleasure to host
today Peter Rigby who is right now a PhD
candidate at the University of Victoria
is studying under daniel German and
Peggy story it's about to finish in a
few months he actually is going to be
talking about peer review in open source
software he had an XE paper in 08 that
examined this and then he also took it
further and hex he has an upcoming ixy
paper in hawaii in may so he's going to
give us kind of a everything he's
learned about how open source peer
review works so with that introduction
here here's Peter thanks so yeah this is
what I've studied for my dissertation to
a peer review and open source and does
anyone know where this quotation comes
from computers are useless they can only
give you answers you know who said that
anyone know you got a thing outside of
the computer world actually think
Seattle yesterday actually for the last
couple weeks yeah baby that's not
helping I oh that doesn't help you
actually forget that
hmm yeah as Picasso and there was the
Picasso exhibit there was just an intent
casa yeah wake up with never everything
yourself mother good I don't know what
the Casa would take it to that oh yeah
he was a connected awesome anyways out
of the exhibit was was pretty fantastic
that's he's one sort of interesting
fella hey anyways back to the research
so yeah peer review and open source um
so this was my dissertation work which
I'll be totally defending this term but
these are the sort of the main steps of
my research so the first I wanted you
know I'll inspection and so the peer
reviews been around for over 35 years
now and what we have a good sort of
understanding of it in industrial
development or and an open source
development claimed you know yet you
know all I bought up many I boat any
eyeballs make all bugs shallow there was
never really like any empirical stuff on
know how many costs involved is this
actually efficient in this kind of stuff
so I tried to give sort of an empirical
basis to some of the claims that there's
massive peer review and open source for
example so we started off with just
looking at the different processes that
successful software project excuse so I
focused just on successful ones in this
work and just just at sort of a policy
level how do they conduct peer review
and then the next thing I did is I sort
of started quantifying quantifying
various aspects of peer review and for
me I just look at how they do it on the
mailing list so Tom's actually looked at
it in bugzilla in this kind of stuff but
for me it's these these broadcasts on
the mailing list as well as like post
commit reviews where it's like posted
after it's been committed and then
there's a review so I've sort of
statistical models of the efficiency and
effectiveness of this in various
parameters that I look at and while
these numbers are interesting they don't
really give you an idea of how of how
developers actually interact during the
review how they actually find within
this sort of broadcast of patches and
development discussion the actual
reviews that they're interested in
reviewing and how they deal with things
like Parkinson's Law
says you know people discuss sort of
trivial issues to death and when you
have lots and lots of potential people
who can discuss stuff do we sort of get
overwhelmed and deadlock in this useless
discussion right so how do they deal
with these sort of interactions so that
lost parts are more qualitative so first
of all why do people do peer review and
Weinberg noted that you know when you're
writing your own code you just are just
unaware unable to see sort of these
stupid little errors that you have you
see what you want to see as opposed to
what's actually there and then when you
invite appear to actually look at it
they're like oh well the problems
obvious you know and they pick up your
little errors so that's sort of
fundamentally what peer review is all
about getting someone else to look at
your code and there's all kinds of
different techniques and sort of the
most formal one is formal inspection
which was sort of introduced by Michael
Fagan at IBM about 35 years ago and it
was very rigid and reg reg regimented in
the sense that there was a single goal
and you didn't step outside of that goal
so you were finding defects and that was
it he didn't discuss anything else
during the inspection meetings that all
those two kinds of discussions were cut
off and you had rigidly defined roles so
there was a moderator a reader or viewer
these kinds of things and it was
typically done what was done on large
completed artifacts right so you
finished something and then you gave it
to these reviewers they went away looked
at it you came back and met and
discussed in multiple meetings any
issues that you had found sort of
overtime that process as well there's
also sort of walkthroughs that our bus
sort of less formal so there's been many
different variations on that process
that has made it less formal and sort of
more mena bellossom to developers who
don't actually often enjoy doing these
really formal reviews and often aren't
engaged and therefore don't find as many
defects sort of at the other end of the
formality spectrum is pair programming
where you just have someone typing and
someone looking over that person's
shoulder so is this kind of continuous
review but there's no sort of third
party that is that that is also sort of
checking what you're doing and it's just
the two of you that are going at it and
then the
open source so when I looked at these 25
policies of these successful projects
what we saw is the important things is
the commit right here so everything
happens around the time of commit and
you have these two different types you
have review then commits which is called
RTC and commit them review which is CTR
so what happens in the case of review
then commit is you say i have this patch
people come and they say well there's
this particular problem with it or do
you think of this and then there's
rework done and then it's committed so
it's before they commit with commit the
review what happens is you have trusted
individuals who are able to modify the
shared repository they make a change and
then it that changes is sent to the
commit mailing list and a lot of
projects have a policy of everyone who
is a committer has to read all the
commits that they go through on that
list and then if they find any problems
there's rework and then there's another
commit or if it's a really significant
problem which happens relatively rarely
it's reverted to the previous commit and
then reworked right the problem with the
review then commit so there's different
styles of review then commit and sort of
one style is a strong style where it
doesn't not even the trusted people are
allowed to commit before it's reviewed
but the problem with that is it's kind
of inefficient because I have to find
someone to always review my code where's
most the time I'm changing these small
i'm doing a small fix and i have to wait
you know for a day while people review
it and it's just slowing me down right
because everything happens around the
commit so certain projects like mysql
use strong RTC another style is
maintainer RTC which basically happens
when there is code ownership so a
project that's big enough that you do
have sort of explicit code ownership
before you can change this part of the
system you have to talk to the
maintainer but the part you own you can
change and do sort of the commitment
review style so there's a number of
little variance within this but those
are the two main types of overview so um
I looked at 25 different projects but
then i looked at six projects in detail
and
they range in size from sort of Apache
to like Linux and no all large
successful projects that are you know
the first four sort of infrastructure in
the last two are sort of an ecosystem of
projects which include sort of end-user
stuff I have a variety of like these are
the number of threads like message
discussion threads than the number of
each style of review and the number of
commits over that particular time period
that I studied i started with apache
just because it was relatively small and
had relatively well formalized processes
and then moved to subversion which was
in some ways a literal replication of my
first case study because it was very
similar to apache so if i didn't see
similar stuff going on and probably
wasn't no capturing the right phenomenon
and then went up to linux which is much
bigger and you know it has a dictator as
opposed to this sort of this community
right and then finally to these these
these ecosystems style projects so I'm
just going to give you my serie of
open-source peer review so what I found
from on my research and then i'll
present sort of each how each of these
pieces come sort of into it so what i
found is that the way it's done in open
source is you have early frequent
reviews so that's really they're just
reviewing basically all the time a very
small chunks of code and these chunks of
code have to be independent and complete
so you can't have like you can't be
doing like a bug fix and Riaan denting a
whole bunch of unrelated files they'll
just be like no sorry give us the bug
fix and give us the indentation in two
separate patches so they have to be sort
of logically and functionally
independent as much as possible and as
small as possible and it's done
asynchronously so it's broadcast to this
mailing list and so there's a
potentially really large group of
stakeholders in the hundreds or
thousands but what we actually see is
that only a small group of
self-selecting experts actually end up
finding and doing or actually end up
commenting on the different patches and
i'ma show that it's within certain
bounds efficient and effect so these the
first part where I actually quantify
stuff these are the sort of
Chin's as well as the measures that I
that I look at so the first thing was
review frequency and project activity so
as the as there's more development being
done does the reviewing actually keep up
with it or do we start to see a lot less
reviewed code because you know in many
cases that there there are voluntary
developers and do we serve to start to
see this increased development but not
increase reviews how many people are
actually participating so are we talking
about thousands of people in a
particular reviewer is it actually more
like what we see an industry with like a
couple people four people maybe
experience and expertise so how who are
the people that are doing this is are
they working in their area and do they
have they been there for a long time or
is it are you getting sort of more
outsider opinions who are the people but
what does the experience and expertise
of those people then the size of the
change to so traditionally you're
looking at big changes or are we're
looking at sort of smaller ones here and
then the complexity of the change under
review so how does this how does the
complexity affect the review and I have
sort of two outcome or dependent
variables which are the review interval
and the number of issues found and
traditionally these have been measured
as the efficiency of the review process
and the effectiveness and sort of
traditional inspection experiments so
the review interval basically says from
the time the author says I have this
piece of code that i want you to review
to the time when all the bugs and
defects have been reviewed that sort of
is the calendar time or the review
interval so it doesn't tell you exactly
how long any particular individuals
spent but it's the entire time for the
review and that's usually on the order
of weeks in traditional inspections and
I'm just the number of defects found so
are we actually uncovering defects and I
look at issues as opposed to D folks
which I'll get to a bit later just
because the developers don't record this
was a defect that was a defect so I had
to think of some other way of measuring
that so the first thing is a sec before
going so I used these parameters in my
models of efficiency and effectiveness
and then I was like
I'm just going to talk about you know
what influence they had when I do each
each parameter so frequency this is a
graph of freebsd and you can see that
this is sort of each point is a month
and you can see that you know in like
sort of relatively like the 2000s or
whatever we're up and thousands of
commits a month right and then for for
commit them review we can see there's
about like ten times less reviews and
this means about like one in ten so the
one of the problems with the data that i
have is if there's no problem found I
can't differentiate between whether it
was ignored or whether it was reviewed
with no issues found right but what what
I found when I actually went through
manual and looked at them as they they
typically don't respond if there's
nothing to talk about right and so you
can see that about one in 10 reviews
bring up an issue right the correlation
between the number of commits so project
activity and the number of commits them
reviews is around is above point and
across all the projects so as as as
activity increases so too does the the
frequency of review with review then
commits which is which is it's not
committed you first you say can you
review this and then it's later
committed the correlation is much
smaller so it's moderate something
between like point three and point six
and I'm not exactly sure what the reason
for this is but a lot of those patches
are rejected so this is usually coming
from outside people and so you know
these are conservative projects they're
not necessarily interested in your
latest feature and so it seems like they
have they're much less responsive to
sort of these outside or patches as
opposed to the do pay attention to the
ones that are committed because this is
what is affecting the system
collating with like a time lag yeah I
did to review before commit you may
expect that it's like village up to the
next month or something I did do auto
correlations but as we'll see the day
the the length of these reviews is
really fast we're talking like on the
order of hours to days and so it's
really difficult to choose the leg like
it's basically this if it'll be within
like a few days usually so yeah so um
yeah you can see that there's a high
frequency so these people are sort of
constantly reviewing stuff so the next
thing is participation so as I've said
the sort of the group of people who have
commented on the man list is in the
thousands right um the the the problem
with the data that I have is that you
know in a traditional inspection and
experiment you have 0 4 people came to
the inspection meeting that's the
participation these three people talked
and that person do anything because I
don't really have that information I
just have this email list thread and I
have you know the patch and then people
respond to it right so I only so if
someone has you know bruh viewed it but
they only found the same problem as
someone else they're not going to
respond right so I only know the people
who actively participated I don't know
all the people who maybe did the actual
review so what I did is I took all the
reviews for a particular month and I
said if you respond at some point if
you're doing reviews at some point
you're going to be the first problem
person to find a problem and you're
going to respond and if you don't you're
really not contributing that much of the
project so I said that's the review
group that's the group of people who are
participating in reviews and that's what
this is and you can see it's highly tied
to the size of the project so this
number 16 here is for Apache there's the
size of the people who are participating
in any given month is 16 whereas for
linux it's around 480 and very few of
these people participate in more than
one review and the people who do are the
core people the maintainer of the
project usually those are the people who
participate in a number of reviews so
like five or six reviews versus just one
review where they've had a single common
so the review group is highly tied to
the size of the project but the number
of reviewers for any review is is almost
constant in the median case across all
the projects at two right and so you
have this really big potential group you
have a smaller review group at a really
small number of people in any individual
review all right um the experience and
the expertise of the people involved so
this is in days we can see the author
and reviewer the authors have less
experience than the reviewers so
somewhere between a year and just over
three years is how long they've
typically been with the project so the
way that I measured this as I said okay
at some point you have a commit or first
message and then we have the current
review at this current review how long
is the person been with the project
right so the reviewers have been sort of
like a couple years to too many years
with the project and the commit the
review how the people had a lot more
experience than review and commit and
again this makes sense if you if you if
you're involved in the commitment review
process you're either watching the
commit mailing list or you're have
commit privileges and so probably you
have more experience but I mean even in
the review than commit case we're
talking about usually somewhere around a
year of experience before you're really
they typically involved in these in
these things experience experience this
would say expertise but I looked at the
amount of work that you were doing so
just the number of commits and reviews
that you were involved in and the area
of work so what files you were changing
and these correlated relatively highly
so I just kept the simpler one which is
the amount of work so the number of
commits and in both cases the experience
and expertise so in the interval case
the more experience and expertise
actually reduce the interval so the
greater the experience the shorter
interval I'm not totally sure why and
then in the case of the number of issues
found the more experience you had
reviewer the more issues that were found
and it was always the reviewer that sort
of dominated the influence of experience
so the author was less yes sir I should
its best for that so the author the
author's kind of varied more
inexperienced and there's was less
important in terms of the interval and
the number of issues found than the
experience of the reviewer so the next
thing is patch size and a number of
people have looked at the size of
patches in open source and I think is a
dress was like they're a lot smaller
than they are in industry usually and we
can see that for a patchy patchy which
has like the sort of smallest patch size
we're talking somewhere around 17 lines
of change code so I'm talking if you
have a diff you have the plus and the
minus of lines change I just sum them
together so I added and removed so we're
talking like 17 lines of the patchy and
then Linux i think is the highest some
around 35 lines but i mean these are
relatively small changes when you
compare them to the hundreds of lines
that say lucent was doing during reviews
so again we're seeing really fast
reviews of really small things basically
are really frequent reviews of really
small things so they're constantly
reviewing little things right and also
although we have this big group of
people it's usually these people with
relatively large expertise a small group
of them actually performing the reviews
even though there is a potential for a
large group so the next thing I looked
at with complexity and most complexity
measures just measured the system
complexity which is different from the
change complexity so you might have a
very complex piece of code that you've
just changed one line which is a highly
complex change but you might also change
like many many different files in a very
simple manner but understanding the
interactions between all those files is
as well a complex change so the first
thing that we looked at was turn which
is just the number of lines changed and
then the number of files modified so
this correlated would turn around point
point 6 or a moderate correlation the
number of deaths so this is
usually like if you post a diff and then
the viewers as well what about this and
you post another one those tended that
died correlated only around point 25
with churn and files so these these
three are you know relatively
independent I looked at change blocks so
in a diff you have like this part of the
file changed and then maybe a hundred
lines later this part of the file change
so we looked at the number of hunks so
probably the further apart in the file I
assume would be more complex than if you
change two hunks are relatively close
together and the number of hunks and
this correlated relatively highly would
turn around point eight so I dropped it
because turns an easier an easier thing
to use a directory distance so if you
have usually that often the directory
structure indicates kind of the
architecture of the system so if you
have two files in the same directory
that you change that's probably less
complex change if you change one file
here and want to file a way over here
again this correlated i actually just
correlated around point eight seven with
the number of file the number of files
so i dropped that one um again because
it's more difficult it was just the
average oh yeah yeah um and then the
depth of indentation which is a
broom-handle actually looked at this so
the more basically the more white space
you have before a line the more likely
it's involved in some deep complex
conditional or something like that so
it's going to make more complex but
again this correlated highly with churn
which all complexity measures seem to
correlate with the size of the file so
um I kept these three in my models and
as you might expect the more complex the
longer the interval and the more complex
the more issues found in the code yeah
so the last thing and probably one of
the more interesting things is in terms
of the measures actually is the review
interval and so this is how long are the
reviews actually taking and we can see
that you know in the median case here
we're talking a few hours and and so
actually sorry I have two things here I
have the time for to the first response
so when you post the patch how long does
it take until someone's done a review
and respond and said what about this
right and this is important if you're
talking about commit their interview
right because if I commit something and
it's not until two weeks later that
someone actually notices that I have an
issue then it's going to you know
potentially there's going to be
dependencies on it whereas what we're
seeing here with commit then review the
intervals or the first response is
within a few hours and within a day or
just over a day at the 90th percentile
so they're the first response is
happening really fast within a few hours
and the full interval which is this sort
of darker line here again is also
happening with between a few hours and
one to two days so the chain the reviews
happen really fast and the interval is
also actually really short and this is
so you have really fast feedback which
is again facilitated by having really
small changes kind of doing
co-development together allowing people
to select what they're interested in
what they know and just kind of stuff
this to what do I tribute with you oh
what's motivating people to respond so
quickly is it the culture of open source
development process that's actually this
sort of the second part where I look
more qualitatively so you have these
numbers like so I kind of just postpone
that yeah yeah but yeah so basically we
see that there are these really fast
responses right and it's a really short
interval and clearly it's that was one
of the things like what Audra said he's
like well the patches are much smaller
and open source than industry but we
have no idea why and I think part of it
is you have to review these really small
things all the time and that's what
they're doing its it started off with
the volunteer culture of I don't have
that much
look at this right so I think it evolved
kind of out of that the number of issues
are the models that I have range so I
actually 10 models free because I have
there's two types of review for for
projects so there's 10 models for
interval and the r-squared value ranges
from point2 2.48 I think so a reasonable
explanation of the variance with the
number of issues it ranges from well I
didn't even bother interpreting the ones
at below 0 point to but point2 2.58 so
again reasonable explanation variance
I'm measuring the number of issues was a
little bit difficult initially I just
did it manually but what I realized
basically what happens is they post a
patch the manless and people say okay
you have you know this stuff but then
they just break in they just respond
right like this is just the respond when
you respond you get the little things
and it says what happens if you know we
have this particular thing happening
here right and so this is sort of you
just break the code with your responses
so it's kind of interleaved and you also
cut out any crap you're not interested
in talking about and so you have
basically what i did is i just took the
diff and i said anytime there's a break
like this there's some issue being
discussed so i can't say that it's a
true defect or anything like that
because they don't record that
information and when I tried to do it i
was reading it over and i'm not smart
enough to understand the internals of
apache or linux or anything like that so
it's a little bit outside of what i
could do but i tried to count the number
of issues and again they're really small
patches and you see between one and two
issues / sort of contribution I did it
in autumn ii i started doing it manually
and then I'm like all I'm really doing
is counting the number of breaks
basically right I you can't I like I can
only you could only do it if there's a
diff right like I didn't like if someone
responds to this it's not a new issue
they're still talking about the same
issue right so it was only on the
initial patch that was produced I didn't
because otherwise you just end up
basically the number of issues is
identical to the number of responses
which is totally useless right
and not not valid so that's the best
sort of the more quantitative stuff but
then I didn't really understand as you
asked like how why do they decide to do
the review how do they find these things
why is it so fast why do we instead of
having hundreds of people talking in the
median case just two people so the
research questions that I came up with
is first of all how do they find the
patches within the sort of broadcast of
information then what happens when
patches are ignored so so far I haven't
really looked at that I said I'm only
going to look at stuff that gets a
response because I know if there's a
response they're talking about something
if it's ignored I don't know whether it
was just no defects found or or it was
just not committed right and you
actually looked a little bit whether
stuff gets in kind of a so ignored
patches what happens when patches are
ignored then when the actual review
happens who are the stakeholders how do
they interact and when there's too many
stakeholders how do they avoid sort of
deadlocking and also scalability issues
so while broadcasting might work
wonderfully for Apache which is a
relatively a medium sized project it
might not scale up to something like KDE
or Linux or something like that the
techniques that they use so how do they
do these out of this scale up so i used
grounded theory which is the qualitative
research methodology and i coded 500
instances of review threads across the
different projects i also interviewed
ten core developers to sort of
triangulate my findings to make sure
that what i was seeing was not some to
make sure that i wasn't crazy so the way
that I code it is I basically had on the
the review thread and then I would just
write I would just write what I was
seeing and then abstract that into sort
of these larger themes and then
ultimately you end up with sort of your
core or most important themes so the
first thing finding reviews in a
broadcast
so the big thing here was um this idea
of area of interest in obligation so
typically an open source when you start
doing development you're interested in a
particular part of the system you write
some code as you become sort of
successful at writing code in that area
you are invited to you know be a
maintainer of that area or to become a
core developer and at that point you
start the developers that interview
starts saying talking about obligation
like when I see code in that area I'm
going to review it and this isn't purely
altruistic if I'm maintaining a
particular area of the code and someone
else changes it I'm going to have to
later probably maintain that code so i
have a vested interest in making sure
that this review is a good review right
and fine and um so yeah and yet ensuring
that that's sort of a good a good
section of code so in traditional
inspection it's like you know you three
are reviewing this right you don't
necessarily have a vested interest in
what is under review so you're not
necessarily as actively involved in the
review process so um how did they
actually poll look so in the case of
Linux the Linux kernel mailing list has
a median of 340 messages a day that's a
lot of mail so that's how do you sort of
dig through this and actually find what
you're interested in how do you not
become overwhelmed and so the first
thing is they just had simple mail
filters so well some of them are
actually more complicated one of the
more interesting ones was one of the
main Tanner's for Linux he said I just I
have all the files for my particular
part of the system and I just have a
filter that if there's a diff with one
of those files it just pulls it out into
bi inbox right so all the developers
differentiated between the general
mailing list traffic and their inbox so
if someone sent something directly to
them as well as the mailing list they
paid more attention to it than just the
mailing list and they also had these
filters that would pull out you know if
it came from a particular person that
they usually work with or files or
whatever so they pulled out the sort of
important email to limit what put that
to look at and then the next next thing
is this idea of what I call progressive
details so they
did still look on a regular basis at the
entire mailing list right and the reason
that this is possible is because if we
actually go through this will come up I
did it in an off offline as well see if
that comes up I have all these subjects
that describe what the patch is about in
one line so you can go and kind of read
all this stuff and this allows you to
sort of develop a general awareness so
if i click work offline sorry
this allows you to develop a general
awareness of what other people are
working on so one of the guys talked
about how how like he pays attention to
one of the subversion developer says you
know I pay attention to all the commits
that are going on I don't understand
them at the nitty gritty details levels
but I have a general awareness of what
everyone else is doing on the entire
project and I get this just by following
the commit subjects and by following the
discussion the subjects that that's
going on so what happens is you I'm sure
if you can see that you have the subject
that basically says in one line this is
what the patch is about right so you can
say as you're skimming over the subjects
you say oh I'd know something about that
so you click on our I'm interested in
that and then you have the changelog
which basically says you know these this
is what the patch does at an abstract
level this is why I decided to do it
this way this person also approved it
this is maybe something I don't
understand and I would like some
feedback on this particular aspect of it
you know these are other people who are
involved in it right and so as a
reviewer you come in and you say okay
well I don't really agree at a
conceptual level with what this person
is doing and so I'm just going to talk
at that I'm not even going to bother
looking at their code because there's no
point right and then if you get if
you're like okay no that makes sense
then you get to the last part which is
the actual code and you can discuss sort
of the details of it right so it's this
progressively adding more detail that I
think that I sort of hypothesize allows
them to deal efficiently with what would
otherwise be an overwhelming quantity of
information it's not the right one Ariel
so that's the so the next thing is this
interleaved history so when in my
example up here as you can see the
discussion is interleaved with the the
actual patch itself and you know if
someone when the author responds to this
or this question down here they say well
you know I was doing such and such and
that's why I did it this way and so you
start to see these sub sort of points of
discussion being developed and someone
who is coming in from the outside so you
know I haven't been paying any attention
to this review but I see there's been a
lot of discussion maybe I'll look at it
you have the whole history of the entire
discussion broken out into these sort of
subtopics within the actual threat and
anything you're not interested in you're
supposed to cut so you can see like he's
just cut off the top part that he's not
interested in talking about right so
this is this interleaved history the
last part of sort of finding is refined
reviews so if if once I sort of have
found something that I'm interested in a
patch that I'm interested in it'd be
really inefficient if I had to refine
that within the general broadcast every
single time there was a new discussion
point made right and what happens in in
private email when I send if I send
three people in email and they respond
is if they don't add anyone new
explicitly it's going to be the same
people where is on a mailing list I send
it just generally out I don't send it to
anyone explicitly although I could but
when I respond to that I'm added to the
CC list and developers differentiate
between the generalist and what sent to
them specifically so now I get all
subsequent discussion in my inbox so I
don't have to sort of refine this in the
general Raj of discussion it just comes
directly to me so it's just a it's just
a natural kind of property of mailing
lists that allows them to easily refine
what they've been talking about so the
next point so that's how do they find
stuff the next point is what happens
when there's too few reviewers so I'm
asked them like everyone has time
pressures it's slightly different and
open source instead of saying you have
to review these five things it's like
why only have this amount of time to
work on it so
instead of saying I'm going to rush
through and review all these 5 i'm going
to say well this is the number one
priority for me and i'm going to review
this properly and that's what they all
said they said you know i don't i don't
rush the reviews i will postpone stuff
rather than rushing through it and it
perhaps a cultural thing they're not
being forced to a particular deadline
usually but that was the mentality the
definite mentality this is interesting
too in the sense that it pushes the
effort of ensuring that a patch gets in
off the expert and on to the author who
is potentially less expert so i say you
know sorry i don't have time to look at
this now can you send it to me next week
it's no longer the reviewers
responsibility remember i have to review
that so the author will resend it and if
at that point it's interesting to me
whereas the reviewer then i will review
it so instead of being forced by a
manager to review stuff they review what
they're interested in and potentially
they know people who are not competent
or capable just get ignored and you're
not forced to review these people who
you're like this is wasting my time you
just do just ignore them does that mean
they're like they're just so been doing
or use it and it doesn't go in yeah like
that's especially we should die because
no one cares then no one cares and I
mean it it's a bit of a like an elitist
problem but it's a slightly different
problem than what like at least the
people are interested in active in in
what is interesting right and it's this
it's this selection sort of almost
natural ish selection of what is
interesting and what is useful / just
what I have to do so the actual review
discussions the the interviewees and
sort of what I actually saw as well can
be broken sort of into two categories
the purely technical discussions and in
this case usually it's accepted and
understood that that the the code is is
necessary and useful but it's just like
going through and and you know well this
is obviously poor code and reject it or
you know you've made this little problem
but in the in the other case it's it's
the scope or politics kind of
discussions that none of the developers
look they all tried to avoid these kinds
of things right so someone will come on
and say what in
you write it this way we really need
this feature and these often end up
being like really over specialized fix
so you know I optimize the the colonel
in this particular way and it's like
well that screws over our like
ninety-nine percent of our users so go
away please you know you can maintain
this yourself we don't mind but we're
not going to include it and you end up
in this this political discussion one of
the interesting things is especially in
these conservative mature projects is if
there's no obvious significant
improvement it doesn't get in so you'll
actually see lenez torvalds he'll be
like well I don't see the performance
numbers being that much better sure the
codes a bit cleaned up but it's not
hasn't been tested well enough so it
gets rejected so there's nothing really
wrong with it it's just they keep what
they know works over what doesn't work
because again i was looking at mature
relatively stable project so it might be
different on sort of smaller newer
projects um or does that are they able
to quantify that as a significant I
think you could do that you could
definitely do that but you have to show
that there's obvious benefits right so
it has to be clear to the person who's
doing the reviewing that there are these
benefits and you have to argue them and
if you aren't able to do that and you
the other thing is sure you can do a
whole bunch of code refactoring that's
fine wonderful but if it hasn't been
tested it's not going to get it so it
doesn't necessarily mean that they're
not going to take it at this time we're
not willing to take it go find a whole
bunch of people to test this on their
machines and come back and tell us right
and then maybe we'll accept it but as it
stands there's no it's not obviously
better and so we're not going it now I'm
going to take it basically the test
yeah exactly i mean
but I guess what's the part because they
do their own testing it's like a match
absolutely i mean it kind of varies
depending on the trust of the person
who's written the code how important it
is if you have obvious benchmarks that
can show performance like there's
definitely a lot of a case-specific
stuff that will determine whether it's
better or not but at the end one of the
reviewers one of the maintainer 'he's
will decide whether it's it's it's
better or not right and I mean I think
was lynus in what is I think he did a
tech talk at Google he talked about how
testings for wussies or something like
he would say and he's like it whenever I
write code I just handed back down to
one of the maintainer zor whatever and
then it gets tested if it makes it back
up fine if it gets dropped I don't care
you know it's good has to go even stuff
that I write has to go sort of through
this process of making sure that it does
get sort of run by a bunch of different
people and tested in that sort of loose
no he says I don't do testing I pass it
back down to people like my maintained
errs and like other users and that kind
of stuff and if the code that I've
written makes it back up to me again
then I'll include it but if it doesn't I
don't care because it just didn't sort
of satisfy this criteria of being like
better yeah a significant improvement
right one of the things that they did
point out to me though is think it
doesn't stop new features like they will
change like we realized this is the
direction we need to go and these are
the stepping stones that were going on
but then it's sort of we've planned for
this like this is the direction that
we're moving in and you know maybe it's
going to get a little worse for a little
while but we know this is where we're
going right so it doesn't stop
significant new features but if you're
just rewriting something because you
think it's going to be faster and it
turns out to only be like mine like a
minuscule amount faster than it just
doesn't get included so I want to ask
them about roles I didn't see any
explicit rules and they didn't really
they were like rolls
like there's not really like there's no
like reader or moderator these people do
kind of come up but they don't just sort
of naturally exist and so these were the
sort of personas or ways that they acted
so the objective analyzer which is kind
of the goal of peer review your
objectively looking at the code finding
bugs this is sort of the mentor role as
new people are coming on as i talked
about you have to generate interest
around your patch in order for it to get
accepted and then just like we've
already talked about this go away kind
of just grumpy cynic we've already tried
this we've been down this road go read
that discussion and leave us alone and
then this is kind of the resigned where
you're like okay I don't care just make
a decision I don't care which decision
it is they're all fine kind of thing
which is the bike shed effect which I'm
going to get to next in terms of
outsiders for the most part they said
outsiders the core reviewers were like
the outsiders that sort of mixed
opinions about them so long as they're
competent and objective and they're not
sort of have a particular ideology that
they're not willing to leave they can
actually be quite useful so the
different types of useful ones which are
sort of the rare outsiders are aspiring
developers external developers so that
you know you're writing an
infrastructure projects like Apache and
then there's a bunch of modules around
it so they're writing their own code and
they realize there's a bug thats related
to the code that they're working on and
they'll actually sometimes correct it
for you in your product and then give
you a particular piece of code and then
power users one of the subversion guys
said you know we have these sites that
run huge subversion repositories and
they bring up issues that are outside of
the scope of the core development team
right so they're useful in terms of
discussing what is necessarily what
needs to be in the product right and
sort of giving more a broader
perspective to the development team so
the too many opinions I wanted to
measure Parkinson's Law of triviality
which is trivial stuff gets discussed as
death and one of the things that they
were that that is noticeable in one of
these discussion threads is that usually
there's not a lot of core developers
there's a lot of outsiders making noise
so I said how how often does this
actually happen
review so the number of review threads
that are involved that involve at least
one outsider you can see that outsiders
are involved in a reasonable number of
threads however they're rarely the
majority of people so most of the time
it's the core developers who are in the
majority in terms of how much so if the
more the more the larger the number of
outsiders they the shorter the time to
review the fewer total messages and the
fewer core developer messages so kind of
basically something similar to what you
found is that the higher your status the
more likely people are to talk to you
and so the outsiders really although
they're involved they're not sort of
dominating the reviews and ending up in
these sort of pointless trivial
discussions for the most part and that
resonated with with the people that I
interviewed as well kind of getting a
little low on time but I this last part
is sort of the scaling issues so we can
see that Apache this is the number of
messages per day along with the top axis
logged and you can see that Apaches
around 3040 messages whereas Linux down
here in this is the median number of
messages a day is around 340 messages
this is a single mailing list um Kate
FreeBSD KDE and gnome had 90 130 and 200
and 200 different mailing lists right so
topic-specific mailing lists when you
sum them all together they're relatively
similar to Apache so around or Linux
around 200 but the top individual list
was actually really small so around the
size of Apache right so this is the
first way that they kind of dealt with
scale is by sort of chunking stuff into
these different mailing lists so you
subscribe to a subset of what you're
actually interested in the the concern
that I add here is well this kind of
isn't broadcasting anymore you've
isolated these people into little groups
and now you're not getting this sort of
outsider input anymore right fume so I
looked at how many messages crosscut
various lists so if you were to send to
my
multiple lists then you would again be
kind of including a larger population
but very few messages and email threads
actually crosscut multiple lists what
ends up happening is that many
individuals are subscribed to many lists
and they kind of bridge the lists
together so they they're aware of what's
happening here there where what's
happening there and they discuss the
different point so they're on many
different lists so the guys that I
interviewed were subscribed to somewhere
between five and thirty different
mailing lists I thought you know the
people who are probably bridging the
community so or that are on the most
lists are probably the higher status
developers so the ones doing the most
committing this was only a moderate
correlation so it's not completely one
to one so I guess probably what the
problem here is that you probably have
developers who are just really focused
and do a lot of committing and have no
interest in anything else right so it
would be interesting to look at who are
the people who are doing the bridging
what is there sort of what what's their
makeup right because it's not just
completely related to your development
status in the team lot the next thing is
some Linux didn't-didn't doesn't bother
it does have multiple lists but the l
kml list is huge its massive it's bigger
than like the 200 gnome lists has 350
messages or for any messages a day so
it's like this what is happening here
and what I noticed was that message is
sent to the Linux kernel mailing list
were sent to the mailing list but they
also usually had well they had people
that were also cc'd so individuals that
were cc'd so they were broadcasting
stuff but they were also saying you
might want to look at this as well right
so they were sending it directly to
particular people so I said well is this
basically what is what's going on here
is it as the broadcast basically broken
down and we're sending it to particular
people or do people who don't explicitly
receive this also respond so this is the
requested so a message has in the medium
case around four people that it's
actually explicitly targeting the number
of people who are explicitly targeted
targeted that
respond oh sorry this is plus one I was
wondering what I was like that's right
because I couldn't log zero so instead
of one so it's around four so the number
of people who who are explicitly
requested so it came to my inbox in the
median case around one person responds
but the number of people who implicitly
respond so i didn't actually receive
this but i'm still found it interesting
and respond was again around one for a
total of two people to reviewers that
actually responded so basically they've
combined them to combine this idea of
broadcasting with Tarkus specifically
targeting people i don't really have a
lot of time i guess for this part but
although like formal inspection kind of
is quite different from open source
review a lot of the findings around
around sort of the advances in
inspection are very similar to what a
lot of the open source developers are
doing right so vota and porter and those
guys found synchronous meetings don't
discover more defects so you can do you
can do it's basically that preparation
phase you that's where you find all the
defects so why he found you know twenty
percent of the interval so the weeks
spent doing the the calendar time was
just wasted waiting for people to meet
basically so do a synchronous meetings
is where they found there's a lot of
other things that you can get out of
doing peer review that you don't when
you restrict the goal to solely finding
defects so in the open source thing we
saw like mentoring you can bring new
people onto the team this kind of stuff
this also happens relatively easily in
an asynchronous environment to to
reviewers typically find as many as four
so they found that by adding more people
you weren't finding significantly more
defects and the number that they came up
with was to which is naturally what open
source gravitates towards in the median
case there's two sort of people who are
involved either obviously can be as many
as you want in some cases balls are bugs
although to shower because apparently
more violence doesn't equal oh I'm not
it's it's it's fun it's what it actually
is the the best predictor of the number
of defects found that the like Porter
and those guys found was the expertise
so the expertise is the best predictor
right so having competent eyeballs is
much more important than lots of
eyeballs at least in that's what they
found right and one of the nice like an
open source there are some reviews that
have 20 people involved right and so
you're not restricted to only two people
it's just two people tend to interpret
matters because they're small changes
you have more people in
promise much that's only a certain set I
about to say something that's actually
an interesting point what I think is
because so if you have a really large
artifact you're going to need expertise
for a variety of places whereas if you
keep the artifact really small you don't
necessarily you need the the people who
have the expertise don't necessarily
need to communicate with each other and
so they just review the small chunk that
they're interested in right and it's
this idea of self-selection say you're
reviewing this it's just like this is
something that I have that I would like
someone to look at and it's like well I
know something about that right so it's
really optimizing that idea of let's get
the right expert on it right which is
which was shown to be the best predictor
of things and the large large artifacts
are simply just difficult to review like
it divides stuff in you conquer it right
and by having sort of co-developers in
an area you have people who understand
it so the preparation time is basically
dill it's like I understand this part of
the system all I need to know now is
what you've changed right so the
preparation time is almost zero and
bipartisan and Mazzilli they have this
idea of active reviews because they were
noticing people were just not involved
and active enough in the review process
but open source kind of takes it too
well we're co-developers I oh I don't
necessarily own this but I'm interested
I have a vested interest in making sure
this is a good review so it's kind of
beyond almost active and it's invested
agile these are just there's agile an
open source are pretty similar but the
big thing here is distance and scale
right so agile sort of depends on this
sort of osmotic communication right so
you have everyone in a small room and
you kind of hear in the background what
people are talking about and and you
pipe up when you know something
potentially right or you just tune stuff
out so I think I think this idea of
broadcasting and using the mail this
could help agile actually scale to a
larger thing because i mean it is
osmotic communication right you have the
all these subjects and your peripheral e
aware of what's going on you know what
other people are working on you pipe up
when you know stuff right but it does
work and these hugely distributed large
projects right which agile has difficult
scaling up to so in summary this is kind
of the main sort of points that I found
so early frequent reviews which gives
you lots of feedback early on of small
independent complete chunks to sort of
divide and conquer stuff asynchronously
the meetings really don't help
synchronous meetings aren't necessary
you have this potentially large group
but what you end up with is people self
selecting and you end up with a small
group of actual core reviewers and it
does find defects and it does happen
pretty fast so that's it any questions
from here
cool oh thanks a lot guys